[Music]
I came across this Tik Tok of this girl
on a Subway in New York you don't even
need to see it just
listen what is he doing just screaming
she just sitting and there's a lady just
screaming on the subway like and this
goes for probably another 30
seconds someone said the Tom and Jerry
scream oh that dude infra Bren posted a
brutal one dude what this is this is the
only real cringe left we'll come by our
fluids and mix them all up fun times
included you know what's up come to the
territory oh no don't mind me Ross Dress
for Less more like uh Ross undress for
Less
right I wish it was Ross undress for
Less oh you're a hoot yeah I'm Brad nice
to meet you Glen Bren Bren Jer yeah Bren
nice to meet you yeah BN yeah got a lot
of good feels a lot of um clearances
going around you have the creamiest
little
handshake clhs as Kenneth would say
remember this
that you want to sip of my drink oh no
you sure you look
parched oh I had my bra it's fermented
eel sploot oh nice 100% pure eel
ejaculate wow yeah never even know there
was that thing right now you
do it's just this I hate I hate it dude
it's I hate it it's how is this guy just
going this guy is kind of nice though
yeah that's what that's what all the
comments were about like how did you guy
back to work buddy all right well before
we get back to work you want to get a
picture together like a selfie or
something oh come
Onix it over here hey
bud care all right hey what are you
doing later oh I'm I'm doing my own
thing oh cuz I rented out in the Walmart
parking lot and me Kenneth and the boys
were going to be playing some hemorrhoid
Hunters going to Comedy I think the
laugh is so bad yeah oh my God what a
what a
this is lowy deleted scene from get out
bro what a what a nice diversion there
what are you doing later I'm doing my
own thing
yeah it was a really great way of
putting creamiest little
handshake you have the creamiest little
handshake you saw that other one where
it was like it was captioned
uh don't mind my laugh or don't mind our
laughs yeah dude walks out the bathroom
and his friend filming him tells him a
joke and then laughs at his own joke for
10 minutes straight it's a 10-minute
video you can scrub through and every
second it's
like the kids stand the whole time like
oh my God you got to find that okay I
love those yeah yeah that was good man
shout out to
brenn shout out Bren I like the ones
where it's like the Y
records yeah like people like put a
timer on their computer and then they
just like Yap for 2 hours and speed it
up so good yeah bro such a [__] waste
of time it's insane
dude like imagine like this is this is
yapping yeah we're [__] yapping we
are yapping but at least we're like
keeping it at one time of speed so you
can understand what we're saying I mean
isn't everything just yapping
D you want to get deep Whoa We you know
we I mean what do you want to YF about
you want to Y about religion or
something no I don't I've been getting a
lot of that on my uh discover on my
Instagram discover religion Christian
rappers no way I like you know cuz the
algorithm is so obvious yeah I watched
one and now I just have a oh man I got a
roll a decks of these guys really is
Christian rap
evolving and I sold him save me and
they're just did you save any of these
yeah I have so many [__] send them
dude this could be our guys of the
week there was there's this one dude no
it's like it
it it feels bad why they're just they're
in their own world I feel like a lot of
those guys do paid ads too they do to
promote their music they do yeah and
that they all say the same [__] does
Christian rap go harder than Reg rap is
Christian rapable no no it doesn't it
will never will the first Christian rap
to go harder than regular rap is there
Christian
EDM yeah yeah okay oh and then the
debates that these guys spark are so
great in the comments you can't take
something worldly and put God on it and
make it for God this is still worldly
music what is worldly like material
of the world Satan all that [__] I think
what's really like above all what's
really funny
is a lot of these dudes I'm
seeing they all very distinctly copy one
artist oh
yeah and
uh it they're damn near just rewriting
these artist songs and then the funniest
one I've come across is all the the R&B
Christian R&B and they sing about and
South Park's already made fun of this
but like they sing about God like
wanting to [__] God it sounds super
sexual it's like and then he laid me
down yeah yeah and took it all from me
you're like what the [__] it just
doesn't seem right like you're talking
about God yeah yeah so whatever yeah but
yeah there's one in particular I'm
thinking of where he pretty much rips
Travis Scott one for one okay and it's
about God and it's just very funny yeah
but it he doesn't have like a massive
account so I feel shitty being like
yeah yeah a lot of Christian rap I do
want to see this though I'll pull it
it's so show me after it's so good but
now I'm I'm like unironic or sort of
ironically into it no it's just now it's
all my feed yeah yeah yeah it's just a
hell of Christian rappers some of them
they uh they they very obviously mimic
all the mannerisms of a like a regular
rapper like
they'll one that's funny is like the
walk him
down uh like mannerism like and you'll
hear rappers say like walk him down like
we're going to kill him yeah yeah and
they'll use that language and those
mannerisms with talking about like
walking in Jesus's footsteps it's just
it walking on water it doesn't work dude
it doesn't work it looks so weird what's
funny about like Christian music is that
like it's all they sing about yeah but
you don't have to if you're a Christian
artist you don't have to always sing
about your religion you can just sing
about love like everyone else yeah or
things yeah or things or whatever
mhm I think it's a obvious for some of
them it's an understanding that if they
it's going to get the plays yeah it's
going to get the numbers it's a huge you
can go South Park they did this already
triple you know [__] fur and
crysanthemum or
whatever you can go quadruple platinum
in the Christian category I feel that
this has been a thing but there's never
been a time to access
Christian F like Believers this readily
and it's not going to be often that they
see a Christian rapper so if you're a
this is basically the beginning of
Bitcoin yeah for Christian
rap